why do tech companies have so many
employees well the answer is that they
not only over hire but most of these
employees end up working on things that
will never see the light of day things
like weather balloons that are supposed
to increase internet connectivity
underwater cameras for ocean Farmers AI
That's supposed to increase agriculture
light that can enable wireless
connections these are all projects that
Google is working on right now and that
those are just a few of the public ones
the reality is that most of these
moonshot projects don't end up going
anywhere but they do end up requiring a
lot of employees and the resources